putin dessen rede die welt erschüttert
sie haben es gerade in der unterzeile
gelesen in der ganzen welt die reaktion
eiligen einhellig natürlich eine
zurückweisung dieser
völkerrechtswidrigen anerkennung und
besonders groß ist das entsetzen
natürlich vor ort in der ost ukraine
da ist auch unser reporter paul
ronzheimer aber hier sehen wir zuvor
noch einmal die ersten truppenbewegungen
das ist der bilder die über twitter
gegangen sind die wir aber also gutes
ging verifizieren konnten in der tat
sind erste truppen in bewegung gesetzt
worden wobei man dazusagen muss dass
sich ja viele russische truppen aber
wenn auch nicht offiziell bereits in der
gegend aufgehalten hatten und sich jetzt
einfach nur zeigen weil es nichts mehr
zu verbergen gibt paul ronzheimer ist
vor ort für uns in der ost ukraine wo
bist du ganz genau und wie sind die
menschen dort heute morgen wach geworden
wie reagieren sie
thomas ich bin in konstantinov das ist
wenige kilometer von der frontlinie
entfernt von der linie entfernt wo auch
bislang schon kämpfe waren wo bislang
schon krieg waren nur jetzt ist die
große sorge das ist ein großer krieg
wird dass putins truppen auch hier in
dieser stadt kommen die bislang unter
kontrolle der ukraine ist man muss sagen
dass die situation sich dort massiv
zuspitzt wir haben von quellen dort die
bestätigung dass russische truppen
bereits durch einzelne straßen gefahren
sind wir haben eine bestätigung durch
lokale quellen dass es dort weiterhin
eine generalmobilmachung gibt ich hatte
gestern die möglichkeit mit jemandem aus
dem netz also aus der separatisten
hochburg die unterstützt wird und jetzt
anerkannt wird von putin zu sprechen er
hat mir gesagt dass es dort checkpoints
gibt dass dort männer eingezogen werden
und er hat gesagt ich will nicht in den
krieg deswegen lasse ich mir die finger
oder die hand brechen freiwillig damit
ich dort nicht hin muss also auch da
gibt es unterschiedliche sichten wobei
zunächst einmal man sagen muss ist eine
große große mehrheit in diesem
separatisten gebiet mittlerweile gibt
die sich darüber freuen
sehr wahrscheinlich dass putin das jetzt
an erkennt dann die situation in der
gesamten ukraine man muss sagen dass die
sorge groß ist dass eben diese truppen
die jetzt hier im dom bass sind noch
weiter fahren könnten noch weiter in
richtung und die erste einrichtung kiew
gehen könnten vitali klitschko der
bürgermeister mit dem ich gerade eben
telefonieren konnte dort bereitet man
sich vor auch auf eine zivile
verteidigung die bunker sind vorbereitet
das hat ja auch schon unser kollege
peter hell von dort berichten sie lenski
der ukrainische präsident auch er könnte
jetzt in großer gefahr sein us quellen
berichten dass man ihn aufgefordert hat
nach levi nach lemberg zu gehen und sich
dort zu evakuieren wenn russische
truppen weiter hier richtung kiew ein
falls die wut und die sorge derjenigen
die hier kokain ist prowestlich sind die
skos auf den westen auf deutschland
insbesondere mir sagte ein freund am
telefon wie kann es sein dass ihr immer
nur über eure wirtschaft spricht habt
ihr vergessen was mit der berliner mauer
war wie es euch ergangen ist also hoch
emotionale stimmen hier über das was
passiert ist sie sagen wir haben euch
gewarnt ihr habt eine politik verfolgt
angefangen mit frank walter steinmeier
mit angela merkel mit gerhard schröder
natürlich auch und jetzt seht ihr was
passiert ist putin war nicht bereit mit
euch zu verhandeln er hat euch wie uns
alle wie immer war er einen schritt
voraus und das ist die wut die es
momentan auf den westen gibt und
gleichzeitig die angst davor was hier in
den nächsten stunden passieren könnte
wir hören von der front das ist bereits
wieder mörserbeschuss gab die große
frage ist jetzt wie reagieren da die
russischen truppen
paul wir werden daher auch nach lemberg
schalten zu unserem reporter findet
offene der dorthin geht die amerikaner
haben ja auch ihr botschaftspersonal
dorthin verlegt von dort jetzt auch
sogar noch abgezogen aktuell so dass gar
keine amerikaner mehr permanent vor ort
sind auch das spricht natürlich für eine
eskalation was wäre das für ein zeichen
wenn der ukrainische präsident seelands
gibt tatsächlich kiew verlassen würde
was wäre das für ein zeichen auch an die
bevölkerung
das wäre die komplette kapitulation wenn
er das machen sollte aus meiner sicht
und das kann ein ukrainischer präsident
wenn er denn im amt bleiben will wenn er
präsident bleiben will nicht tun ja kann
nicht den präsidentenpalast verlassen
das erinnert mich das ein bisschen an
die situation die ich in afghanistan
erlebt habe mit dem damaligen
präsidenten ashraf ghani der dann
irgendwann aus geflogen ist und damit
war es vorbei also ich glaube wenn sich
ja sie lenski weiter richtung westen
ziehen würde dann weiß putin okay er hat
gewonnen er kann jetzt weitergehen oder
er kann jemand installieren den er
installieren will denn das ist bei aller
großer sorge aller großer angst
natürlich die frage was ist putins
bereit weiter hier auch zu riskieren
also wird er mit den panzern jetzt in
den nächsten stunden nächsten tagen noch
weiter ins land gehen und je weiter
westlich geht desto größer ist der
mögliche partie sagen widerstand auch
das muss man sagen denn auch wenn es
einige geben würde hier zumindest im
osten die sagen wir wollen einfach dass
dieser krieg aufhört lasst uns sozusagen
jetzt versuchen hier irgendwie friedlich
zu sein und auch noch eine stärkere
bindung haben richtung russland trotz
allen dem was passiert ist in den
vergangenen jahren je weiter westlich
man geht je weiter man richtung kiew
richtung lemberg kommt desto größer ist
der ukrainische patriotismus und zwei
menschen die ich lange kenne die dafür
stehen wie
symbolisch dafür stehen sind wieder den
klitschkos und wladimir klitschko die
mir beide immer wieder gesagt haben wenn
ich die frage mensch es ist wahnsinnig
gefährlich für euch was ist wenn
wladimir putin kommt wenn die truppen
kaum es gibt todeslisten auf denen wir
stehen werdet sie mir immer wieder sagen
nein wir bleiben in unserem land wir
sind nicht bereit unser land zu
verlassen und wir sind bereit für unser
land zu kämpfen jetzt hat man ja das
gefühl dass die ukraine zum zweiten mal
die wange hin also auch die zweite wange
hinhält nach der krim ist jetzt die ost
ukraine de facto besetzt russische
truppen sind wir haben die bilder
gesehen du hast es beschrieben kann sich
die ukraine das eigentlich gefallen
lassen guckt man da weiter zu oder ist
streckt man einfach an dem punkt jetzt
erst einmal die waffen volle übermacht
die russen
bislang hat der ukrainische präsident
alles versucht angebliche provokationen
zu unterlassen aber das hat russland ja
nicht davon abgehalten zu sagen dass die
ukraine die russland angreifen also er
macht aus dem was der tatsache ist
verdreht er die dinge macht linken
daraus und hat für diesen vermeintlichen
angeblichen kriegsgrund erst gesorgt und
den druck auf no mercy lenski das
ukrainische truppen das land verteidigen
müssen wird natürlich größer und die
frage wird sein ob auch der westen
überhaupt noch imstande ist würde mir
die lens gibt davon abzuhalten und zu
sagen lasst uns weiter verhandeln da wo
wladimir putin bereits tatsachen
geschaffen hat und er könnte auch
innenpolitisch unter druck geraten denn
da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
sichtweisen darauf natürlich gibt es
diejenigen peter die sagen wir müssen
alles mögliche blutvergießen verhindern
aber es gibt eben auch die
hochemotionale und das muss man ja auch
sagen verständliche sich darauf dass man
sich das nicht erlauben lassen kann das
war die mit putin einfach panzer in die
ost ukraine schickt und jetzt auf
ukrainischen land steht das ist ja die
tatsache wir haben das alles erlebt in
den vergangenen jahren das natürlich
schon russische truppen da waren aber
erstmals hat erst offiziell gesagt diese
vermeintlichen friedenstruppen die dort
stehen und was ist mit den soldaten die
da ihr land verteidigen die ihre
kameraden verloren haben was ist mit den
menschen den zivilisten die getötet
wurden sollen die sich das jetzt
anschauen und sagen wir tun einfach
nichts und warten bis wladimir putin
auch bei uns im vorgarten steht was
sollen wir vermeintlichen garantien den
glauben wenn putin jetzt sagen würde
okay dieser teil des dollars reicht mir
ich gehe nicht weiter wer sagt denn dass
in ein paar tagen in ein paar wochen er
sagt jetzt habt ihr mich vermeintlich so
provoziert dass ich doch weitergehe also
das ist eine ganz ganz wichtige frage
die duh gestellt hast und die antwort
kann ich dir nicht geben aber ich glaube
die gefahr ist riesig dass es hier wo
ich gerade stehe
wenige kilometer von der front zu einem
heißen zu einem großen krieg kommen kann
es ist der absolute wahnsinn pause sind
im jahr 2022 heute sogar der 22 22 01 22
und wir reden wieder über krieg über
einen großen krieg in europa danke dir
für die eine sache vielleicht noch
thomas näher ja ja okay meine seite den
22.02 weil du den 22 222 ansprichst auch
das haben wir in den vergangenen tagen
bei bild berichtet man hat aus
verschiedenen geheimdienstquellen diesen
tag immer wieder genannt als den tag der
invasion und wir erinnern uns in
georgien ist putin am 8 8 2008
einmarschiert als ich vor drei wochen
hier mit annalena baerbock in tier von
auch im osten war da haben wir
ukrainische diplomaten bereits gesagt
wir haben angst vor diesem
22222 weil putin ist in crazy numbers
putin mag verrückte zahlen und ist es
tatsächlich so gekommen das
provozierende das schlimme was das
russische außenministerium gemacht hat
stunden vor putins rede hat man bereits
im twitter-account diesem zweiten den 22
222 ersetzt also das zynische spiel
putins ist auf allen ebenen angekommen
und es macht die sache einfach noch
verrückter vielen dank paul ronzheimer
für den moment